Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
reciban un cordial saludo desde París si
quieren saber qué pasa en Francia en
materia cultural están en el lugar
correcto y a continuación el programa
que les hemos preparado para hoy
[Música]
el museo de los cuenta la historia de
una crisis creativa la que vivió Matiz
en los años 30 y que revolucionó su obra
posterior
asistimos a una nueva pieza de teatro
sin tambor nos acerca a la cruda
separación de una pareja y explora Los
lazos entre teatro y música
llega a Francia una película colombiana
que habla de los códigos de la
masculinidad un varón es la ópera prima
de Fabián Hernández
y en nuestra Crónica musical visitaremos
una discoteca mítica en la capital
francesa con un festival musical le van
ha sido un trampolín para muchos
artistas
[Música]
el museo de París presenta en estos
momentos una exposición sobre el gran
pintor francés o más bien sobre la
crisis de inspiración que sacudió el
artista en los años 30 y que transformó
toda su pintura Melissa barra con los
detalles
[Música]
de 60 años en La Cúspide de su gloria y
que sin embargo duda de sí mismo y de su
arte es lo que pone de relieve la
exposición Matiz que hay edad el giro de
los años 30 a través de una colección de
obras de museos franceses y
estadounidenses
[Música]
en 1930 Matiz tiene efectivamente 60
años es un artista veterano y a la vez
muy famoso su obra comienza a apreciarse
de forma retrospectiva y eso lo empuja a
hacer un balance de su carrera eso lo
hunde en una profunda crisis de
inspiración que lo lleva a cuestionar
sus pinturas se da cuenta de que ha
hecho muchos cuadros de caballete mucha
sodalistas y que eso ya está pasado de
moda
esta crisis existencial empujó a Matiz a
buscar Nuevos Horizontes emprendió un
viaje a tahití pasando por Estados
Unidos durante el cual recibió un pedido
de un mural Monumental Matiz consagró
tres años a esta obra la danza que le
permitió renovar completamente su estilo
y forma de pintar inventó la técnica de
los papeles pintados y recortados que
marcará toda su obra posterior la
exposición en París presenta un cuadro
de Gran valor representativo del nuevo
estilo de Matiz
el famoso desnudo rosado prestado por el
museo de Baltimore es casi un cuadro de
pop art presenta a una mujer desnuda su
cuerpo es rosado sobre un fondo azul y
un tramado de líneas blancas Matiz hizo
20 versiones de este cuadro utilizando
los papeles de colores hasta alcanzar
una forma estilizada casi abstracta en
este cuadro
la exposición muestra una de trabajo
apasionado a veces doloroso diez años de
crisis de los que Matiz sale triunfante
la exposición comienza con un cuadro
pintado durante la crisis es un retrato
muy bello de una mujer pero donde puede
notarse La angustia de matisse es casi
un combate contra la pintura y
terminamos con un Lienzo completamente
diferente la blusa Romana de 1940 una
mujer con una hermosa blusa blanca muy
estilizada una composición equilibrada y
serena Matiz se reinventa entiende que
su pintura es un acto mental Y lo
demuestra
[Música]
Carrusel de las artes los lleva ahora al
teatro para asistir a una pieza
contemporánea de gira por Francia sin
tambor es una obra tragicómica que
relata una ruptura amorosa donde todo se
desmorona pero siempre con música
todo comienza con la ruidosa separación
de una pareja que se desgarra en gritos
y reclamos ella quiere poesía imagen su
vida el más pragmático le habla de
facturas y de un fregadero que ya no
funciona mientras se disputan se
desploma el apartamento donde viven al
tiempo que una soprano y cinco músicos
acompañan la acción Esa es la historia
alocada de sin tambor del director
francés Samuel ashall
[Música]
la pieza arranca con la separación de
una pareja cuando deciden separarse todo
alrededor se derrumba también la pieza
habla entonces de lo que queda luego de
una ruptura de lo que cada quien decide
hacer con lo vivido y con lo que ya no
existe Y qué hacemos con las ruinas de
una relación
sin tambor Integra la música de Los
líderes de Robert schumann el compositor
emblemático del romanticismo alemán y
melodías originales Antonio es
clarinetista y compositor
[Música]
San Miguel y los espectáculos de Samuel
la música es muy importante no solo para
acompañar sino que es un actor más sobre
la escena utilizamos la melodía de
schumann pero también hay composiciones
originales y En algunos momentos
musicalizamos los diálogos de los de las
fuertes actual
[Música]
es
sin tambor es un original teatro del
absurdo tejido con fragmentos de
historias como nos contó la dramaturga
lucille
los líderes en música canciones de que
cuentan pequeñas historias de amor no
sabemos Qué pasó antes o después así que
nos dimos la libertad de imaginar la
historia completa y luego a partir de
esas melodías se compusimos el resto de
la música del espectáculo
[Música]
pasamos ahora nuestro bloque de cine
destacamos una película colombiana en la
sala francesas esta semana un varón
explora la masculinidad tóxica y
agresiva
así cualquiera
a lo que es mero cuerpo de niña es la
historia de Carlos un adolescente que
vive alejado de su familia en un
internado de Bogotá y que debe aprender
los estereotipos de ser un macho pero en
la intimidad es un ser sensible que
descubre sus miedos y otras formas de
ser hombre un varón es la primera
película del colombiano Fabián Hernández
en la película se expone un muchacho que
de puertas para afuera tiene que asumir
un rol que es el rol del varón de que
soy capaz de que no me da miedo de que
estoy dispuesto a hacer lo que sea con
tal de no ser menos que los otros con
tal de no ser estropeado pisoteado y en
el fondo es una presión tan fuerte que
que lo llevan a dejar de pensar en lo
que lo bello que es él en sí mismo
un varón se rodó en el barrio donde
vivió su director en la capital
colombiana pero visibiliza tratamientos
que pueden verse en otros países
Sí en Latinoamérica en Colombia si se
firma mucho como esta posición de la
mujer como víctima y como el hombre como
victimario pero yo también creo que hay
espacios para ver por qué De dónde viene
esta cosa de de posición casi política
en la que él tiene que matar para tener
una posición social matar al otro es muy
extraño para mí
enfréntate a la vida porque tú naciste
para sobrevivir
[Música]
ahora ya para nuestra Crónica musical
Natalia Olivares fue a visitar un hotel
cinco estrellas un lugar único que
mezcla cultura bienestar underground y
música y allí tuvo lugar un festival
100% parisino la Natalia Hola María
Carolina Y por qué es un festival tan
excepcional primero porque el festival
leván tiene lugar en un lugar patrimonio
histórico de la ciudad de un hotel cinco
estrella como lo decías también porque
reciben una multitud una multitud de
músicos que irrumpen en la escena
musical francesa y tercero y sobre todo
porque es gratuito Jonathan folín el
organizador nos recibió con los brazos
abiertos
esto tiene lugar en un hotel
independiente este festival se
autofinancia y es gratuito el objetivo
es destacar la escena emergente y que
sea accesible durante tres días rompí el
agua el propietario quería preservar el
ADN de esa mítica sala lewandows de
París en 2015 se transformó en hotel
pero se mantuvo el ambiente de los
conciertos que se hacían en los 80 con
Prince Depeche Mode y muchos más David
Guetta también pasó por aquí en los años
2000 Así que guardamos ese lado novedoso
pero recibiendo a pesos pesados como
christov para cells
o la fam la cosa es que la gente vuelve
a hablar del lugar
[Música]
levántese llamaban
parisinos y también grandes estrellas
internacionales esa mezcla de estilo
perduró resistió al tiempo y ahora
teoatlanie uno de los programadores nos
habla de esa de ese secreto de esa
programación llamativa y eficaz que
mezcla set y también conciertos
Tenemos muchos estilos musicales
programados tanto proyectos más en
música urbana pop rock y también muchos
proyectos Electro ya que el festival
está abierto hasta las cuatro y media de
la mañana tenemos diferentes tipos de
público Hay personas que vienen a un
concierto específicamente otras que
vienen por la sorpresa hay un flujo
entre los que van y vienen y los que se
quedan toda la noche
[Música]
y Eso sin contar a los programadores de
la industria musical que vienen a
detectar nuevos talentos entre ellos el
grupo chispa musical el grupo later que
obtuvo su ticket para la quinta edición
de este festival
[Música]
un satélite nos llamamos later más tarde
porque queríamos algo que sonara en
inglés Esto significa también que
estamos un poco fuera de ritmo vivimos
más lentos y asumimos esta idea de
ruptura para nosotros fue una forma de
mostrar que somos una banda
independiente
[Música]
gracias Natalia Olivares por habernos
presentado ese festival le van y para
despedirnos con un poquito de ese
ambiente de fiesta nos vamos a despedir
con el tema back to heaven del grupo Los
lateral Muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]